thirteen-year-old Karina went on a
summer camp to Russia and never returned
her mother in Ukraine is frantic with
worry
she shows us a picture of the children
heading off on the trip last month
Russian troops had been occupying their
Village and told the parents the camp
would be a break from the war and can
you remember the last conversation that
you had with your daughter
security
Days Later a Ukrainian counter-offensive
ended the occupation but the Russians
retreated without returning the children
Natalia had this message for her
daughter
um
Russia was accused of forcibly
relocating hundreds of thousands of
ukrainians during this war there's no
indication the summer camp was a ploy to
steal children
Moscow doesn't seem to be helping those
stranded to return home
nine-year-old Polina also joined the
camp and hasn't been heard from since
her parents say they can't afford to
travel to Russia to find her and don't
even have passports
personally
she too had a message for her little
girl
kazacha lopan is a broken Village after
six months of Russian occupation
at least 11 other families sent their
children on the summer camp to escape
the combat
locals say those parents then left with
the Russians when the Ukrainian forces
arrived
none have yet returned
debraham Sky News kozhachalopan